hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round 12 of defeated
candidates tournament it's young shirt
of duda versus saliresafirojan and it uh
does remind us of the uh of the previous
game elitista played against nipple
where he lashed out with the pawns on
the king side here it's similar to that
but with uh with uh with a bit of a
twist
during the game as you'll see so let's
check it out we have a nice photo of the
matchup there we have it the duda versus
salireza with their uh with their suits
and shirts matching the color of the
pieces they are they are playing with uh
so you know just two two very nice
gentlemen playing chess let's enjoy that
for a second and then we are off as the
game is quite uh quite enjoyable uh do
that with the white pieces opens with
the d4 we have knight to f6 c4 e6 knight
to f3 and d5 so a standard queen's
gambit declined knight to c3 ended the
semi slap defense pawn to c6 with e3
knight beat to b7 and queen to c2 so
that that there's just a whole lot of
theory uh from this position uh
nothing new happening here uh for the
moment bishop to d6 bishop to e2 and
both players castle so castles castles
and now d captures on c4 we wait we
force white to waste the tempo as the
bishop already played the move bishop
character spawn to b5 bishop back to d3
and bishop to d7 a3 alireza grabs more
space on the queen side pawn to a5 and
now uh point the e4 grabbing more space
in the center e5 by le reza forcing some
trades on the e5 square the captures we
have knight captures knight captures
bishop captures and now pawn to h3
uh this is very much needed because you
want to play f4 if you play f4 right
away then brush up d for checking h1 and
knight g4 with queen to h4 and knight to
f2 coming this is just terrible for
white so h3 we are going to play a f4
but at some point in the future uh
bishop to a6 by ali so this is the the
the start of the game basically it's not
a new move but it's an incredibly rare
one i believe um
so far employed only by alexei shirov
one of the uh greatest attackers ever
and uh alireza finds the inspiration in
his games he should have used it twice
he used it once against levon aronian
one again once against daniel dubo and
even though both of dogs those games
ended in a draw uh they were quite
quite the games so bishop to e3 uh duda
just continues development and pawn to
b4 now attacking tonight and offering a
trade of light square bishops so do that
goes for the trade bishop captures b
captures on c3 bishop back to c4 and now
c captures on b2
alireza gets a pass pawn on b2 but rook
8 d1 attacks the queen and now comes the
tricky move queen the e7 now offering uh
uh dude to play bishop to c5 to go after
the queen and the rook and this is
exactly what duda does and it's exactly
what she'd have played in both of his
games against um arunian and dubov as
it's very well analyzed
but it's uh incredibly tricky bishop to
c5 we've reached the position from the
thumbnail and now of course the bishop
cannot be captured we simply play bishop
captures on f7 and pick up the black
queen so of course something else has to
be played alireza plays bishop to c7 uh
queen to c7 and now bishop captures an
f8 rook captures an f8 and pawn to g3
now it's important to block this
diagonal and also we want to have
support for pushing f4 and in the game
uh against uh arunyan alexey shirov
played pawn to c5 and this is in fact
the the strongest move uh sorry in the
game against dubois that was played
but uh alireza plays something
completely different and something very
very awesome so here c5 is one of the
engine's top recommendations the move
that shiro played other suggestions or
something like queen to b6 and g6 but it
is a place g5 uh and it is now i'm sure
you can imagine as of move 22 that we
have a completely new game so a lot of
theory uh up to this point but the g5 uh
is just incredibly interesting because
if duda doesn't play that one move that
gives him the advantage uh then he's
just gonna be worse now or rather
the position might even be equal it's
just that alireza knows way much more
about the position than duda does uh and
he finds it he finds pawn to f4 this is
the absolute strongest move um uh
white can play here and the reason is g
captures g captures uh and now you you
kind of have to capture the the pawn
here or you don't uh already captured
you could also play bishop to d4 check
and after king h2 just cemented the
bishop with c5 the bishop regarding the
pawn on b2 looks very nice for for black
but after e5 uh the position really
opens up towards uh uh towards that
black king and it's not going to be the
bishop also very strong so white would
be better here uh it's just a question
of uh how much uh but alireza grabs the
pawn instead and this is uh even more
trickier uh queen captures on b2 by duda
attacking the knight here uh and the now
knight to h5 at defending the bishop on
f4 one more time you could also play
bishop to e5 but um after bishop to e5
we play queen to g2 with check king h8
and now it seems like black is doing
okay but there's this very tricky queen
f3 move uh that leaves the black
basically without a move you can give
this one check but after king to h1 uh
it's it's a crazy position both players
are attacking but it's just that uh you
know black black doesn't have anything
more than the attack and white also has
the attack but white also has the extra
material white has a rook for a knight
so white would be much better here but
alireza goes knights to h5 instead and
now we have to do some rook lifting here
rook to d3 or rook to f3 is the way to
go dude that chooses the d-rook uh queen
to e7 uh now uh centralizing the queen
the the queen's influence is great from
from the e7 square able to come to g5 to
h4 and so on and now rook to f2 by duda
and this is where duda drops the ball uh
quite a lot uh king to h1 and it will be
very very hard to play this position
with black it's a it's a very uh um
it's a much needed tempo uh where you
don't really have a good move here
because if you play queen captures an e4
for example we just force the queen
trait queen to g4 queen the g queen the
g2 check and now after the straight
captures captures we are more than happy
with this end game we're up the exchange
of course the position will be
completely completely winning for us
uh there's not another good way to play
this with black so basically what he
would have to do after king to h1 is go
for bishop to e5 instead attack the
queen and now after this queen to g2
check
a very important tempo king h8 queen to
g4 another important tempo knight to f6
and queen to f5 and white's position
improved drastically with black uh
struggling to to even find the move here
so that's the way to go but in the game
rook to f2 was played and this allows
alireza a free move bishop to e5 now
attacks the queen queen to e2 goes after
the knight and now alireza plays knight
to f6 here uh alerissa could go for
knight to f4 it's uh it's a very nice
idea attacks the queen attacks the rook
and it's basically a force to draw uh
but uh you know it's important to check
it out if queen g4 check we're going to
move the king now rook d7 attacks the
queen seems like
black is getting destroyed however there
is this queen captures an a3 looks like
a funny moment to grab a pawn on the
other side of the board uh but it's
actually that from this side of the
board we are attacking this side of the
of the board uh so that's why it's a
good move and now after something like
rook captures on f7 it's a forced line
knight captures an h3 with check king to
g2 knight captures an f2 attacks the
queen rook captures an h7 for it looks
like white might have something but
there isn't anything the best white has
this to just force a draw here with
queen h5 and go for a repetition here as
our good friend the bishop covers the f7
square so uh larissa can just basically
grab a draw here with knight to f4 but
he plays knight to f6 hard to say if he
calculated everything or he wants more
than a draw but knight to f6 again just
allows duda to play for the win king the
h1 now finally freeing the
uh g file for for the white rook uh king
to h8 black does the same and rook to g2
we have rooked the b8 now by alireza uh
trying to get some action on the on the
first rank and now bishop to a2
preventing this knight the e8 uh and now
comes queen to e3 uh here again it's uh
the the position should be winning for
white but it it it's just that there
isn't you know anything that uh proves
this like we could uh continue improving
our position queen g4 threat and
checkmate uh knight d6 so the rook
defends against checkmate and now
there's even this beautiful rook d to g3
move where we are again threatening to
checkmate the black king with a with a
queen sacrifice but after queen to d8
there's just uh
there's not a
there's no first win here white is
winning and white should win after some
time has passed and some moves have been
played it's just that there's no you
know the the finishing blow that
everyone is is hoping to see but yeah it
is an overwhelming position uh but
instead queen to e3 was played and now
knight to d6 by alireza and here rook
back to d1 queen to c5 again keeping all
the tension is is very strong for white
um it's just uh
the problem is it's not clear how to how
to force a win here white is up material
uh but uh
you just can't uh get anything decisive
so rook to d1 was played uh and then now
comes queen to f6 biologist rook to f2
attacking the queen queen g6 and rook to
g1 now again putting pressure on the
queen uh saying that you will not be
able to capture on e4 because i just win
the end game but that's exactly what
alireza does as you know the the
alternative is just terrible once you
move the queen we start capturing and uh
then black is just lost so queen
captures an e4 queen captures knight
captures and now uh duda plays rook
captures on f7 and this basically forces
a draw a very tricky move to find is
actually rook f the g2 uh now with the
idea that okay we're we're still
attacking the pawn but if you move the
pawn we just deliver checkmate let's not
forget about our good friend the light
square bishop covering the g8 square so
you're not going to be able to do it
this way but you can play rook to f8 and
now black rook is passive it's it's a
very tricky position to play white will
always be better but with perfect play
probably not enough to win the game but
after rook captures on f7 it's just very
easy for alireza to force a draw here
knight to g3 with check king to g2 and
now rook to b2 with check forcing a
trade of rooks because otherwise you're
going to lose the bishop on e2 so rook
to f2 rook captures uh king captures and
now we have bishop to d for check nicely
connecting winning our material back
king captures sorry king captures on g3
bishop captures on g1 and he was in this
position on mu 41 that duda and um
agree to a draw uh as there is nothing
more to be done here yes
is up upon but it's you know bishops of
opposite color and the black king is uh
way back in the corner on h8 there there
is no hope
here uh for uh for for alireza to do
anything with his extra pawn of course
both of them know this and they agreed
to a draw
uh so yeah really really awesome stuff
so like i said it's it's um it's not
really uh lashing out like in the game
against the nipple without the g4 h4 but
even that i even though everyone is
calling it you know lashing out you know
he played too many blitz games uh
without nipple finding the absolute
strongest only line that destroys uh
that idea
it is very much playable it's just that
nipple found it here duda did not find
that he he rushed it a little bit he
couldn't um uh you know push for more
than a draw here and here it kind of
kind of paid off for alireza he gets a
draw with the black pieces but still i'm
pretty sure he did not play this g5 move
to to get a draw he he prepared this to
gain
more than a draw
and even with the absolute strongest
reply from duda it was possible but um
you know yeah
it's just very very hard to play
positions like these
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it let's not forget uh to check
out the standing so here are the
standings after round 12 yanipanishi
leading with eight and a half uh two
full points ahead of hikaru nakamura and
ding liran
then we have rajabov and kirwana with
six out of twelve uh rapport with five
out of twelve duda with five out of
twelve and alireza uh in last place with
four and a half out of twelve so uh uh
with nipple leading by uh two point
margin and we only have two more games
uh until the end of defeating candidates
tournament this means that if nepo gets
only one draw uh he wins the candidates
tournament so he has i believe uh he
still has to play against uh duda and
the rapport and if he uh gets a draw
against either of them uh then uh
yanipongoshi will win defeated
candidates tournament and challenge
magnus carlsen for the title or if
magnus will not want to play then
whoever gets uh second place will be
facing yaniponishi for the title so that
seems to be the most likely outcome but
you never know uh you know we've seen
weirder things happen in the chess world
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it really crazy stuff by by both
of them already trying uh you know with
everything he has but he's just not uh
catching a break here uh i would like to
thank uh michael hoff consulting ellen
chevalier more uh oprah mishkovich
jeffrey cook and abhishek babu for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day